I think a lot of runners are discouraged
that shoes have become such a huge focus
in a sport that used to be seen as so
elemental it was just about your
training and your fitness and you on the
open road and this shoe technology
controversy has changed all that people
wonder where was this regulation earlier
they feel like not all brands were given
the same chance to develop this
technology that may be the spirit of the
rules was largely ignored for several
years on January 31st world athletics
track and field's world governing body
released new regulations about shoes
worn in elite marathon competition in
the wake of a record-breaking times from
runners wearing Nikes vapor fly shoes
the regulations set specific limits
about the height and composition of
distance running shoes soles can be no
thicker than 40 millimeters and any
rigid plates must be in one continuous
plane 2020 is an Olympic year the
January ruling means athletes can wear
prototypes in February's Olympic Trials
but any new shoes must be available at
retail by April 30th if they're to be
worn at the Tokyo Olympics so how are
shoe companies scrambling to match Nikes
vapor fly technology well I think the
first objection by critics was the
timing because world athletics you know
had received complaints about these Nike
shoes or concerns at least for at least
the past two or three years and yet it
took until January for them to take any
really specific action so I think
competing brands were saying hey this is
an Olympic year this is incredibly
important for not only development of
our technology but also for our
competitors who have their highest
profile competition the US is almost
unique in the world in that it holds
trials for the Olympic marathon team
most other nations hand select their
marathoners but in the case of the US
you have to finish in the top three
among women are men to qualify of course
that makes it incredibly important that
you're in shape and that you have a shoe
that can beat other runners earlier this
year the Wall Street Journal studied the
vapor fly asking experts to de-sect the
shoe to demonstrate what some athletes
and critics say give the shoes an
advantage
second you can see the full-length
carbon-fiber plate and this carbon-fiber
plate
adds a lot of stiffness and stability to
the shoe as well it's a race to the
spring deadline for brands to release
shoes if they haven't already but
contain a carbon plate and comply with
the New World Athletics regulations
while hookah onaona is Shu comparable to
the vapor fly technology has been out
since May 2019 we'll see debuts from
brands like saucony with their endorphin
Pro would be released globally on April
15th Brookes will publicly launched
their Hyperion elite shoe on February
29th
but announced five days before the
Olympic Trials that some of their elite
athletes will be racing in the next
iteration the Hyperion elite 2 which
will hit the market in late April ahead
of the April 30th deadline adidas is
adizero pro will be available to the
public in select markets from April 1st
and worldwide by May 15th New Balance
released their fuel cell TC in February
and Asics will release their meta racer
shoe in spring but Nikes athletes may
wear the new Alpha fly on February 29th
it does have a thicker sole than the
vapor fly but the brand has said it will
comply with the new regulations
privately especially to one another some
runners who run on competing shoes have
expressed concern about whether theirs
will match up not only with the current
Nikes but these yet unseen new Nikes I
think some athletes and brands feel that
Nike has too much influence in the sport
it's the leading brand in performance
running shoes and sponsors many many
athletes sponsors USA Track & Field the
president of world athletics is a
longtime former Nike sponsored athlete
competitors worry that maybe that
relationship is a little bit too close
with the body that's supposed to be
regulating it when asked about the
body's independence from Nike World
Athletics responded in a statement we
need to balance what is currently in the
market at an elite level and draw a line
by prohibiting shoes that may go further
than what is currently on the market
until further research is undertaken and
that no shoe company was directly
involved in shaping the regulations a
nike spokesperson said in a statement to
the Wall Street Journal we believe the
new world athletics rules will stifle
innovation over the long
term ultimately impacting athletes
consumers and fans Brook said in a
comment to the Wall Street Journal
generally we would spend more time
between prototype and bringing issue to
market but the recent W a ruling pushed
us to reassess or go to market strategy
one of the reasons why these questions
about shoes are so important is because
running isn't only for elites last year
in the u.s. about 50 million people went
running at least once and if there's a
shoe that someone thinks is going to
make them run a half marathon or a 10k
faster they might be very interested in
buying it so this is not only a question
for elites but it's also a question for
the market